-Depuis le 24 février 2022,
à la télévision,
sur les réseaux sociaux,
on assiste à des combats acharnés
dans les villes ukrainiennes.
Avant la guerre en Ukraine,
la lutte contre Daech
a elle aussi été rythmée
par des opérations dans des villes
du Mali, de Syrie
ou d'Irak.
Stalingrad, Berlin, Grozny,
Falloujah, Gao, Mossoul ou Raqqa,
la bataille urbaine marque
l'histoire des conflits
de ces 80 dernières années.
La guerre sera-t-elle désormais
urbaine ?
Comment fait-on
la guerre en ville ?
Dans ce "Journal de la Défense",
des civils et des militaires
racontent de l'intérieur
leurs combats en milieu urbain.
Depuis deux ans de guerre
en Ukraine,
la ville est au coeur de l'action.
Encerclée, bombardée,
parfois rasée,
elle est un théâtre
d'opérations privilégié.
En octobre 2022,
le ministre des Armées,
Sébastien Lecornu,
annonce une vaste offre de formation
à des milliers
de soldats ukrainiens,
avec au programme, notamment,
de l'entraînement au combat urbain,
une demande spécifique de l'Ukraine.
-Les noms des batailles
en Ukraine
sont des noms de villes.
On s'est battu pour Kherson,
on s'est battu pour Marioupol,
et évidemment,
on s'est battu pour Kharkiv, Kiev.
Donc, l'enjeu de cette guerre,
ce sont les villes.
Maintenant, la ville est redevenue
un lieu de champ de bataille,
et je dirais même le lieu
du champ de bataille
privilégié des combats modernes
depuis pratiquement
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
C'est là que, véritablement,
on a commencé à donner
des noms de grandes villes
comme lieux de bataille,
comme Stalingrad
évidemment, mais Berlin et d'autres.
Puis, avec l'urbanisation
croissante des sociétés,
forcément, mécaniquement,
vous rencontrez
de plus en plus de villes.
Les villes sont des endroits
où on peut se protéger,
en réalité,
le mieux de toute la puissance
de feu de l'ennemi.
-Quand on regarde
l'histoire des conflits,
la ville n'a pas toujours été
le lieu des batailles.
Historiquement,
on assiégeait une ville,
on combattait autour,
mais on combattait
rarement à l'intérieur.
C'est au début du 20e siècle
que la ville devient
un champ de bataille
et qu'on commence à voir
dans tous les conflits
la conduite d'opérations d'envergure
dans cet environnement urbain.
Au milieu des années 90,
il y a
des événements particuliers,
comme le siège de Sarajevo ou,
hors des Balkans,
la bataille de Grozny,
qui alimentent une réflexion
sur les engagements en zone urbaine
et la nécessité
de se doter d'outils d'entraînement
et de développer
des doctrines spécifiques.
-Il y a près de 30 ans,
en avril 1992,
la ville de Sarajevo,
en Bosnie-Herzégovine,
est assiégée.
Sous mandat de l'ONU,
la France envoie des soldats
protéger les populations civiles
dans la capitale bosniaque,
dont le colonel Michel Goya,
alors lieutenant,
chef de section
au 21e régiment
d'infanterie de marine.
-Ce qui m'avait frappé,
c'est, en réalité,
lorsqu'on est entrés dans la ville,
le vide de cette ville,
c'est-à-dire que vous avez
une ville en guerre,
ou ville assiégée,
En réalité, vous voyez personne
ou très peu de gens,
car tout le monde se cache,
tout simplement.
Il n'y a pas de circulation,
par exemple.
Vous avez l'impression
d'être dans une ville fantôme.
Les seuls bruits que vous entendez,
c'est des bruits de véhicules,
souvent les nôtres,
qui se déplaçaient,
et le bruit des balles et des obus.
Donc, ça vous plonge
dans un contexte même cognitif,
même sensoriel,
qui est complètement différent
d'une ville normale.
Des sirènes retentissent.
La ville recevait en moyenne
250 obus chaque jour.
D'ailleurs, au passage,
c'est une des dernières
grandes expériences que l'on a
d'être pris
sous le feu de l'artillerie
à grande échelle.
C'est une ville tout en longueur,
avec un axe central
qui a été baptisé
"Sniper Alley",
parce qu'il était
sous le feu des snipers.
Quand on est arrivés,
d'ailleurs, ça n'a pas loupé.
On est arrivés.
Au bout de deux heures,
on avait déjà perdu un soldat
qui avait été frappé
par un tireur,
probablement bosniaque, d'ailleurs.
Parmi les problèmes tactiques
qu'on a eu à résoudre,
c'est celui de :
comment on fait pour faire face
à ces gens qui nous tirent dessus
depuis des maisons ?
Avec cette contrainte
qu'on n'a pas le droit,
en tant que Casques bleus,
d'aller dans les maisons.
On peut juste se défendre
contre ces gens-là
qui nous tirent dessus.
Il y a tout un tas
de savoir-faire
qu'il a fallu inventer,
réinventer, en réalité.
C'est des détails,
mais c'est un combat assez compliqué
où il faut tout cartographier,
où il faut tout analyser.
Il y a un combat de statistiques.
Il faut analyser
les sondes des balles
pour savoir d'où viennent les tirs.
Je vous donne juste un exemple.
Ce qui m'a aidé,
à ce moment-là,
c'est que j'avais
toujours avec moi le manuel
du sous-officier
d'infanterie de 1949,
plein de savoir-faire
de l'époque, très concret,
daté de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
et dont un certain nombre
avait été oublié.
C'est comme ça que j'ai appris
comment on distinguait
les bruits des balles,
entre le bruit de la détonation
de départ qui arrive vers vous
à la vitesse du son, forcément,
donc 300 mètres par seconde.
C'était du combat de fantôme.
On tire sur des zones en calcul.
C'est le combat de calcul,
on calcule d'où ça vient,
et à partir de là,
on tire sur des points précis.
A l'époque,
j'avais pris quelqu'un
qui dessinait bien.
Il avait dessiné
toute la zone
qui était autour de nous.
Ca a pris un certain temps,
mais il avait dessiné exactement
tous les bâtiments,
toutes les fenêtres,
puis j'avais baptisé
chacune des maisons, des immeubles
et j'avais numéroté
chacune des fenêtres.
Ce dessin, on l'avait photocopié.
Ce schéma, on le trouvait
un peu partout.
Quand on communiquait entre nous,
je disais, voilà :
"Feu sur le bâtiment Maurice 3."
Ca indiquait une fenêtre précise
que tout le monde pouvait voir.
En même temps,
j'avais pris le temps d'analyser
toutes les distances.
Tout, on appelle ça
un baptême terrain.
Les tireurs n'avaient qu'à mettre...
Sur leurs lunettes,
ils avaient réussi à régler
en fonction de la distance
pour pouvoir tirer
le plus vite possible.
Donc, les années 90,
c'est l'époque où,
en réalité, presque toutes
les grandes armées modernes
se préparent
à ce type de combats.
On crée des centres spécifiques
pour s'entraîner à ce combat
dont on pressent
que ce sera vraiment
le combat le plus difficile à mener
dans les années à venir.
-C'est effectivement en 1999
qu'est décidée la création,
par les armées françaises,
par le ministère des Armées,
d'un centre d'entraînement
aux actions en zone urbaine
qui sera implanté
sur le camp de Sissonne.
Je dispose de moyens
très spécifiques,
des instructeurs spécialisés,
pour accompagner les unités
au combat,
une compagnie interarmes
de force adverse
dont la mission est de jouer
l'adversaire sur les entraînements,
des infrastructures comme celles
que vous pouvez voir derrière moi,
uniques en France et en Europe,
et un système de simulation
et d'animation
du champ de bataille moderne.
Pétarades et coups de klaxon
-Ces fantassins du régiment
de marche du Tchad
entament leur 3e semaine
de formation
avant leur déploiement en Roumanie.
Pétarades
...
-Au-dessus !
-Y a une porte à droite.
...
Exclamations
Pétarades
...
-Je suis au 6e étage.
J'ai une équipe...
-Un blessé léger.
*-Reçu.
41 orange, alors.
C'était une mission offensive
de s'emparer de la zone moderne
de Jeoffrécourt.
C'était une manoeuvre coordonnée
avec tout le groupement
tactique interarmes,
avec un appui
de nos alliés belges.
Nous devions nous emparer,
du sud vers le nord,
de la zone moderne.
Une attaque offensive.
D'abord, une grande phase
préalable de,
ce qu'on appelle, bouclage, où,
finalement, on encercle
un peu la ville à distance
pour renseigner
sur ce qui se passe,
où est positionné l'ennemi,
où il y a des mines,
où il n'y a pas de mines,
afin de pouvoir préparer
notre engagement
par des tirs d'artillerie,
pour qu'il y ait un ennemi
qui soit plus faible
et pour identifier
notre axe d'approche.
Une fois qu'on a fait
cette phase-là,
il y a la phase d'abordage,
d'assaut,
où les sections d'infanterie
vont en tête et sont appuyées
par des éléments de génie
pour leur ouvrir les obstacles
et dépiéger,
s'il y a besoin de dépiéger.
Ensuite, ça se fait
bâtiment après bâtiment,
de manière très coordonnée.
Donc, c'est assez complexe,
car en zone urbaine,
la menace peut venir
de tous azimuts et aussi,
au niveau de la 3D, en dessous,
à gauche, à droite,
devant, derrière.
...
-Ce qui est sûr, c'est que
le milieu urbain
est un milieu
particulièrement agressif
sur deux dimensions.
La 1re,
c'est la dimension physique.
Quand on passe sa journée à monter,
descendre des étages,
passer par des fenêtres,
dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas faciles,
physiquement, c'est extrêmement
engageant et astreignant.
Ensuite, c'est un combat
qui est fatigant psychologiquement
car la menace
est omnidirectionnelle :
l'ennemi peut venir de partout
et être partout.
Il est proche.
Quand on est confronté
à un ennemi à courte distance,
on va s'y affronter
le 1er jour, mais il faudra
reconduire cet engagement
le lendemain, le surlendemain
et pendant une durée
qui peut être longue.
On a entendu,
sur les attaques de Bakhmout,
en Ukraine,
des progressions
de l'ordre de la dizaine
de mètres par jour.
On se rend compte
que le milieu est abrasif,
qu'il permet pas une progression
aussi rapide
que sur un terrain ouvert.
Ca ajoute à la difficulté
physique et psychologique.
Si l'ennemi a un groupe
qui est déployé,
il va falloir
une compagnie en face
pour mettre un terme,
pour pouvoir
affronter ce groupe-là.
On a un rapport qui est estimé
à 1 contre 6-7,
là où, en terrain ouvert,
le rapport de force
est de 1 contre 3.
-C'est la raison pour laquelle
des organisations armées vont
se réfugier,
s'installer dans des villes.
C'est un multiplicateur de forces
pour le défenseur,
un diviseur de forces
pour l'attaquant,
un diviseur
de puissance de feu.
C'est une sorte de zone fortifiée.
C'est un grand fort
qui a été construit par des civils,
d'une certaine façon,
qui est en 3 dimensions.
On est sur des zones
qui sont solides.
C'est dur.
Taper, franchir,
percer des bâtiments,
des grands bâtiments,
il faut y mettre le paquet.
J'ai passé une mission
dans la ville de Sarajevo
pendant le siège.
On était dans un complexe sportif.
On recevait des obus
toute la journée sur ce complexe
et ça résistait.
-Le centre abrite un site
d'instruction unique en son genre :
le complexe de tir en zone urbaine.
Au total, huit champs de tir.
Mais ici, rien de fictif :
l'entraînement se fait
à balles réelles.
-Au-delà des constructions
qui matérialisent
un environnement urbain,
nous avons,
à partir de cette tour de contrôle,
la capacité d'animer
nos champs de tir
et donc de ramener au plus près
l'entraînement du combattant
dans des conditions
qui se rapprocheront
des territoires d'opérations
et de la réalité de l'engagement,
par des bruits de fond,
des bruits de combats,
des passages d'hélicoptères,
d'avions de chasse,
ce genre d'environnement,
mais également des appuis
lumineux ou, a contrario,
des gênes qu'on aurait
sur un territoire
d'opération urbain,
comme la pollution résiduelle
de l'éclairage public, des flashs
d'explosions ou ce genre de choses.
On retrouve,
dans ce complexe de tir
en zone urbaine,
des environnements
qui nous permettent de nous mettre
dans des situations d'inconfort
au tir et bien sûr
réagir à une mise
en situation,
de vivre une embuscade,
donc de réagir
et de se désengager d'une embuscade.
-De par notre expertise,
nous avons aussi
une vocation à observer
et à tirer les enseignements
des conflits en cours
et des engagements
en zone urbaine probables.
Nous échangeons avec des pays
qui développent
des structures équivalentes
de manière à adapter
nos scénarios d'entraînement,
à faire évoluer l'environnement
dans lequel on entraîne les unités,
pour rester
le plus réaliste possible
et coller au plus près
de ce que les unités
pourraient rencontrer
sur le terrain, en opération.
Quand on observe
les conflits
de ces 20 dernières années,
l'Irak, le Sud-Liban, le Sahel
et aujourd'hui en Ukraine,
cela confirme toute la pertinence
et l'intérêt pour la France
de disposer d'un centre
d'entraînement spécialisé
dans le combat en zone urbaine.
-Il y a 10 ans,
en janvier 2013,
la France lance
l'opération Serval
pour bloquer la progression
des groupes djihadistes au Mali.
Le 21 février,
le 92e régiment
d'infanterie combat
dans la ville de Gao.
-Un enseignement important pour moi,
au sortir de ce qu'on a appelé
la bataille de Gao,
sur la journée du 21 février 2013,
c'est que le passage
que mon sous-groupement
avait pu faire au CENZUB,
à Sissonne, en novembre 2012,
il a revêtu une importance
dont je n'avais pas forcément
conscience dès le départ.
Mais il m'a appris,
il nous a appris collectivement
ce qu'on avait besoin de savoir
pour être efficaces en zone urbaine.
Ce pour quoi on a été entraînés,
c'est ce qui nous est arrivé.
Quand on est arrivés sur le terrain
et qu'on a dû intervenir,
je pense qu'on a été efficaces.
J'étais capitaine.
Un capitaine d'infanterie,
c'est un officier qui commande
à peu près 180 fantassins
divisés en 5 sections.
Puisque cette compagnie
d'infanterie avait été transformée
en agrégeant des renforts
en sous-groupements
tactiques interarmes,
j'avais sous mes ordres
à peu près 250 personnes,
250 combattants
de différentes armes.
J'avais avec moi une équipe
du CP à 30,
donc des commandos parachutistes
de l'air,
qui assuraient la liaison
avec la composante aérienne
et aviation légère
de l'armée de terre.
En plus de ces gens
de l'armée de l'air et de l'ALAT,
j'avais avec moi
des sapeurs du 31e régiment
du génie qui ont été
incroyables de sang-froid
et d'efficacité.
Ce qui s'est passé le 21 février,
c'est que, dans la nuit,
alors que les villes
avaient été libérées
et que la population
avait repris sa vie normale,
sa vie quotidienne,
les djihadistes d'un mouvement
qui s'appelait le MUJAO sont arrivés
pour s'installer en défense ferme
dans l'hyper-centre de Gao,
qui est un centre
avec des constructions
qui datent de l'ère coloniale
et des murs qui sont
d'une épaisseur terrible
et qui, donc, constituent
autant de défenses très efficaces
contre un assaillant.
C'est des points quasiment
fortifiés naturellement.
A l'entrée de la ville,
on a été recueillis
par des éléments français
qui faisaient du mentoring
au profit de l'armée malienne
et qui ont pu nous donner
quelques éléments de contexte,
quelques directions générales.
Dans cette direction, le fleuve.
A gauche, la population,
une zone sécurisée.
A droite de cet axe,
la zone des combats, les positions
tenues par les djihadistes
et les positions
dont il faut vous emparer.
Je savais que les populations
avaient été évacuées
et que tout ce qui se présenterait
à moi dans le compartiment
qu'on m'avait attribué
était à détruire :
c'était de l'ennemi.
La vraie difficulté
qu'on a pu connaître,
c'est que l'habitat avait été piégé,
massivement piégé,
par les djihadistes du MUJAO,
avec des grenades,
avec de l'explosif,
avec du fil piège.
On ne m'a pas autorisé à entrer.
Je devais combattre
depuis l'extérieur.
Pétarades
*Communication radio
Rester sur les axes.
Le bâtiment,
c'est une zone inconnue,
mais à partir du moment
où on l'a sécurisé,
c'est un appui possible
pour progresser
vers des objectifs ultérieurs,
se regrouper, faire le point,
se réapprovisionner en munitions,
réfléchir aux ordres à donner.
Là, ce n'était pas possible :
on était exposés aux tirs
en permanence.
Je comprends que,
comme on l'a appris lorsqu'on
était au centre d'entraînement
aux actions en zone urbaine
de Sissonne,
mes véhicules blindés, mes VBCI,
vont m'être précieux puisque,
en fait, ils constituent à la fois
un appui feu redoutable
et terriblement efficace,
mais que ce sont des espèces
de rempart sur roues.
C'est des remparts mobiles.
Ils sont blindés,
solides, protecteurs.
Etant hauts,
ils nous permettent,
en grimpant dessus,
d'avoir des visions possibles
au-dessus des murs et de prendre
pied dans le bâti si nécessaire.
L'infanterie, c'est une arme
de mêlée, une arme
qui va au contact,
qui va au plus près
de l'adversaire, de l'ennemi,
et qui va dans la bagarre,
qui va se battre de très près,
pas à distance mais au contact.
On dit que c'est l'arme
des 300 derniers mètres.
-On se mettra en ligne
le long du muret, sur la gauche.
-C'est l'arme des derniers mètres.
On dit qu'on va chercher
l'ennemi à la fourchette.
C'est vraiment ça, en fait.
On s'est battus au pistolet,
à la grenade, au fusil d'assaut,
au lance-roquettes,
au canon mitrailleur.
Le dernier ordre
que j'aurais pu donner,
c'est baïonnette au canon.
Je ne l'ai pas donné,
mais l'occasion se serait
présentée à Gao, ce jour-là.
On sort de là en étant épuisé,
soulagé, on est fier
de la mission remplie,
parce qu'on sait
que la mission est remplie.
Musique éthérée
-En octobre 2016,
les forces irakiennes,
appuyées par les combattants kurdes
et la coalition, y compris
les Etats-Unis et la France,
lancent une offensive
pour reconquérir Mossoul,
la 2e ville d'Irak,
et chasser Daech.
-Au-delà de la reconquête
de son terrain,
l'objectif de la coalition,
c'était bien de s'emparer du symbole
qu'était la ville de Mossoul,
puisque c'est là que, en 2014,
l'Etat islamique avait
proclamé son califat.
Voilà, donc au-delà
de l'objectif terrain,
il y avait l'objectif immatériel
qui était la saisie
de la capitale de l'Etat islamique.
-Mossoul, c'est la deuxième
ville d'Irak.
C'est une ville tentaculaire
qui fait 2 kilomètres carrés
avec un centre-ville très dense.
Il est dur d'estimer
combien de gens y restent,
mais dans nos
différentes manoeuvres,
on voit qu'il y a
une grande masse de population.
Avant, c'était 2 millions
d'habitants.
Là, on est dans l'inconnu.
Effectivement, on voit
que la vie
continue un peu, malgré tout.
On voit des marchés.
On scrute la ville
rue par rue et on voit
qu'il y a
des activités quotidiennes,
mais ça perturbe vraiment
les opérations.
-A l'époque où le 11e RAMa
se déploie,
notre mission est d'appuyer
par le feu
les opérations des Irakiens.
Toute la coalition sait que,
du fait de la nature urbaine
de l'objectif,
la tâche sera rude.
A ce moment-là, j'étais le chef
opérations du 11e RAMa,
et à ce titre, j'étais,
pour mon chef de corps,
l'officier en charge
de la conception des opérations
et de leur conduite.
Mossoul, c'est une ville
de 200 000 structures,
3000 kilomètres de routes,
que l'ennemi a valorisée
pendant près de 2 ans.
Daech a utilisé des moyens civils
qu'il a détournés :
des tunneliers,
des engins de terrassement
pour créer des abris, des tranchées,
pour créer des caves,
des dépôts avancés de matériel.
Il a créé des pièges également.
Donc, pour les militaires
que nous sommes,
nous savons que, en fait,
un terrain défensif valorisé
comme une zone urbaine
et qu'on a valorisé
pendant deux ans,
c'est en réalité
un objectif militaire
extrêmement difficile à conquérir.
-Reprendre une ville
comme Mossoul,
ça a duré plusieurs mois.
Il a fallu assurer
une permanence H24,
jour et nuit,
dans toutes conditions météo,
pour appuyer
la manoeuvre terrestre
et assurer une présence
de tout type d'avions,
aussi bien de reconnaissance
que d'appui feu.
C'est une reprise
immeuble par immeuble,
maison par maison,
qui implique de grandes précautions
de la part des troupes au sol,
qui ont pu se retrouver prises
sous de multiples tirs
et parfois sans possibilité
de se désengager.
C'est grâce à l'arme aérienne
que nous pouvons accomplir
cette mission de reprise
et de reconquête en milieu urbain.
Je me rappelle
d'être arrivé sur Mossoul,
de découvrir
cet environnement très dense
et d'avoir délivré
tout mon armement
car des forces spéciales
de la coalition
étaient prises
sous le feu de Daech.
C'est là
que je me suis vraiment senti utile
au terme d'une mission
qui est passée
en un claquement de doigts.
Le premier risque auquel
on est exposé,
c'est la sécurité des vols,
c'est-à-dire
les potentielles collisions
qui peuvent surgir entre appareils
qui évoluent dans un volume réduit,
un espace aérien contraint.
Sur quelques kilomètres carrés,
il y avait aussi bien
des troupes au sol
tout plein d'avions
comme des drones,
des avions de reconnaissance
et des avions de chasse
prêts à délivrer le feu
si c'était nécessaire.
Il n'y a pas que nous :
c'est une coalition.
Il y avait des avions de chasse
américains, britanniques.
Tous ces gens nécessitent
des procédures particulières,
notamment d'étagement.
Chaque patrouille a une altitude
qui lui est allouée.
Avant de rentrer dans la zone
et en ressortant,
c'est la déconfliction,
le 1er de nos soucis
avant d'opérer sur ce théâtre.
-En octobre 2016, une équipe Mossoul
a été mise en place
à la direction
du renseignement militaire.
Dans cette équipe,
on a beaucoup de spécialistes,
des analystes Irak
mais aussi des interprètes images
pour étudier
les images de nos capteurs,
les satellites, les drones,
les aéronefs en tout genre.
On a aussi des experts
en cartographie,
des spécialistes de la recherche
en sources ouvertes.
L'idée est d'apporter
notre connaissance vers le haut,
aux autorités politiques
et militaires,
pour les aider
à prendre une décision,
et vers le bas,
vers les forces déployées,
conventionnelles ou spéciales,
pour qu'elles puissent agir
avec la meilleure connaissance
du terrain.
Mossoul, c'est une ville
très compliquée
avec beaucoup de sites sensibles,
des écoles, des mosquées,
des hôpitaux, des universités.
L'objectif va être de savoir
si Daech exploite
certains de ces sites
et si des civils
sont présents.
Si on n'est pas sûrs à 100 %,
on ne peut pas
mener d'opérations.
Mais lorsqu'on sait
que Daech exploite
vraiment pleinement ce site,
on transmet le dossier
aux forces de la coalition
pour que l'objectif soit traité
le plus rapidement possible.
Au-delà de ces sites,
la périphérie de Mossoul
comporte aussi
des usines agricoles
dont les produits peuvent
être utilisés pour la fabrication
d'explosifs ou d'armes chimiques.
Ce sont des sites sensibles
qui sont traités.
Plus généralement,
ce qui nous intéresse également,
ça va être tout ce qui concerne
la fabrication de mortiers
et de véhicules explosifs.
-Ces sites sont protégés
par le droit des conflits armés,
par la convention de Genève,
qui nous interdisent
de cibler ce type de cibles,
des édifices religieux, typiquement,
des barrages, des champs,
des productions agricoles.
En revanche, la protection
qui leur est associée est levée
si ces objectifs sont détournés
de leur objectif :
si l'ennemi
s'en sert contre nous,
eh bien on peut être amené
à ouvrir le feu
sur ce genre d'objectifs.
L'impératif de l'environnement,
notamment urbain,
c'est qu'il faut
une grande précision,
moins de 10 mètres, on va dire,
que notre armement,
on soit sûr qu'il impacte
au bon endroit avec un effet
de souffle
et de fragmentation maîtrisé.
D'où l'importance
d'avoir un armement,
en l'occurrence guidé GPS
ou guidé laser,
avec une tache laser
qui lui indique où il doit impacter,
et avec des corps
de bombe qui, soit,
font une détonation forte,
soit une détonation plus contenue,
si on veut vraiment que la bombe,
eh bien, ne fasse pas de dégâts
autour de l'objectif.
Durant mon détachement,
on avait huit avions sur le parking
qui opéraient jour et nuit
pour participer
à l'effort multinational.
C'était vraiment un engagement
hors du commun
parce que l'environnement l'était.
C'est un des plus gros engagements
de ma carrière de pilote,
dont sur Rafale.
A titre personnel, durant 2 mois,
j'ai fait
entre 20 et 25 missions de guerre,
quasiment toutes
au-dessus de Mossoul, en plus.
-L'engagement du 11e RAMa en Irak,
en 2017,
c'est en termes de nombre
de coups tirés,
le plus significatif
pour l'artillerie française
depuis l'Indochine.
On a tiré, avec 4 pièces,
plus de 5600 coups dans la bataille,
ce qui n'est pas exceptionnel,
mais compte tenu
de la nature de l'ennemi,
compte tenu de ses forces
et de son agressivité,
c'est inédit,
compte tenu des opérations
militaires françaises
des 50 dernières années.
Pour le soldat, ça représente
5 mois de posture d'alerte,
5 minutes, 24 heures sur 24,
7 jours sur 7.
Donc, des séquences
extrêmement longues
avec un sommeil
particulièrement perturbé
et des nerfs mis à rude épreuve.
Je pense que la ville
est un théâtre
particulièrement abrasif
et exigeant pour les forces,
quelles qu'elles soient,
et qu'il doit être pris en compte
pour préparer un système
de force adapté.
-C'est un champ de bataille
privilégié, c'est indéniable.
Est-ce que ça le sera ?
Est-ce que ce sera
le champ de bataille ?
Je ne sais pas répondre.
Lorsqu'on a à combattre,
on sait la difficulté que représente
le combat en zone urbaine,
on sait le coût exorbitant
que ça va représenter en engagement,
en vies, en dommages,
en énergie, en temps,
sans résultat assuré, en fait.
S'engager en ville,
c'est toujours prendre
un risque gigantesque.
Je pense qu'on est heureux
d'éviter au maximum
les affrontements en zone urbaine,
mais malheureusement,
si cela a été tranché,
il faut y aller.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA